you
hi everyone is Gerry Aman chess calms
tactics trainer again let me try three
more puzzles this one it's black to play
and as usual I'm just going to share my
thoughts along the way and hopefully
this time without a tornado or beagle if
you've been around for the last set of
puzzles so okay what's the story with
this one I find this to be a very
appealing move Bishop takes f2 and that
may very well be the answer this I'm
viewing as an unprotected square it once
defended once and after King takes which
is pretty much forced otherwise we win
the rook then there's Queen takes Knight
hmm with multiple threats G to h4 and
hitting this Bishop which is pinned
that's probably it
let me just give this one one one more
quick thought I'm just questioning the
move order is it better to take the
knight first no that's not really a good
idea so I think that the move order is
good originally how I had it Bishop
takes f2 with then Queen takes Knight to
follow so let's run with that
okay that's correct and then Queen takes
Knight all right I guess it was as
simple as that for this first one let's
see if we could get a more difficult one
puzzle two of three okay team white all
right well couple checking squares b5
and h6 call it for checking squares d7
and c4 also this is a free move it's a
it's as if this night since he has a
safe pivot Square he's controlling the
eight squares currently from a5 and
another set of eight because he could go
to d7 with check
so in an instant he can control a lot
more squares and I think this one is
maybe going to result in the fork of the
king and queen let's see like if you
could force the Queen to f6 we're going
to have 97 as a follow-up but there is
always this rook takes a five thing so
let's see candidate moves include what
exactly hmm 97 check right away I don't
think is amounting to anything King c7
what's the follow-up I'm not really
seeing it hmm I wonder ooh I wonder if
there's some quiet move involved I was
thinking of bringing the Queen over here
to guard c2 I have some thoughts of g4
let me let me point that out this has
been on my mind for a little bit this g4
move would force the Queen off of f5 f6
we know what happens 97 g4 the only
other safe square is c2 so that's why
I'm a little bit drawn to maybe guard
the c2 square in some way not quite sure
though hmm like if g4 right away which
is taking the rook so if we let's say
take on a eight first rook takes rook
rook takes rook and then not quite sure
hmm this one's a little bit tricky I
thought it was going to be pretty
clear-cut with some forcing of the Queen
to a square where he give a fork
not quite able to see how to work that
one out though hmm rook takes b5 King
takes b5
I see no good follow up to that they
checking
seven so what rook takes rook rook takes
rook Queen takes rook Bishop takes Queen
not really seeing where we go from there
after G for Queen c2 we're not getting
the Queen
hmm this one's definitely stumping me
here I'm not sure what to even suggest
I'm not I don't know what other
candidate moves I would have four move
one hmm
let's do let's try it let me try this
one again rook takes rook rook takes
rook and then like inserting this check
in between is not really doing anything
still as far as I can tell
rook takes rook rook takes for a queen
takes rook Bishop takes rook and what
Wow
not really seeing it okay what about
what about this actually instead of
instead of taking the rook like that
maybe maybe we could do this move yeah I
think there might be some point with
keeping pressure on b5 what about Queen
d1 or c1 to guard c2 I really do feel
like I'm going off in the wrong
direction with this quiet move to start
but it might be important to do
something like that although we're not
really locked into getting that Queen
are we there's a ton of different moves
black could be playing to defend against
some fork against the Queen Queen d1
Bishop c6 what do you got now not so
much huh what am I missing
I think I'm missing something very clear
but it's not it's not a clear to me
obviously hmm yeah I'm about ready to
give up on this one I don't want to
really devote any more time to it I'm
kind of running out of ideas on this one
I'd hate to give up on it I really want
to get it you have to believe me
Oh Queen a3 is there anything with that
not really
Queen a3 rook takes Queen check here
there's King a6 hang on for a second
there might be something related to that
uh-oh oh my goodness I think there is
Queen a3 rook takes for a queen c5 check
King a six-night d7 and how do you parry
the main threat on b6 you don't oh my
goodness this is it Queen check and then
the silent but deadly move oh man I have
to believe Matt was well you heard in my
voice I was ready to give up on that one
but I I saw that there was some clothes
I saw that this was close to being mate
and he kind of gets stuck there doesn't
he
it's Knight d7 all right I spent far too
much on that one
let's see if we could grab this last
puzzle puzzle three of three okay this
one has to be a little bit less
complicated no quiet moves on this one
hopefully those are always so tricky all
right this comes to mind whenever I see
my opponent tied down
the defense of one of the pieces this
tactic of deflection should really
spring to one's mind can you kick away
the defending piece the king in this
case pawn push in this instance could be
met with Knight takes the king is not
having to take he also has some other
choices g8 but uh there still might be
something related to that
for example after pawn push if Knight
takes now there's the possibility of
let's say some back rank mates in some
lines like if there was some battery
already on the defiled pawn pushed
Knight takes rook d8 would lead to mate
hmm I wonder if this Knight is going to
contribute at all in this puzzle the
contributing pieces will most likely be
Queen rook pawn and Bishop yeah
definitely the bishop because this move
here hmm this pawn push here the knight
would have to take and if he doesn't
then the bishop is there to control that
queening square so I don't think he's
going to contribute I think this this
puzzle will be down to the pawn Queen
Bishop and rook doing something great so
what great things can they do we could
take this knight but there's always this
in-between Queen takes Queen Wolf not
really liking that oh you know what it
might be pawn push Knight takes Queen
takes pawn another well not a quiet move
in this case but after pawn push Knight
takes oh we have the material bounced by
the way don't we actually white is up
upon okay so pawn push Knight takes
Queen takes pawn is hitting everything
well not everything but enough hitting
the bishop and then threatening that
rook d8 idea for me I think this is it
just a pawn push all right that is it
Knight takes and now not Queen takes
Queen the Queen takes pawn
yeah that was it I'm not sure how I feel
about these three I guess the second one
was the most tricky with that silent
move after what Queen a3 Queen c5 that
night that third move 97 was probably
the trickiest of all but um feel free to
share how you did with these and any
other thoughts that you have or maybe
how to improve upon solving chess
puzzles and I'll catch you in the next
video
as always I hope you got something out
of it take care bye
you